This episode is sponsored by Brilliant.org
Whether you are returning to school
Or want to learn a new skill
Such as learning a language or playing a musical instrument
Learning new things is great!
But is there a better way to learn quickly while retaining that knowledge?
The first step is to avoid the laptop.
It may be faster to write on a computer
But writing a paper and pen is the way you take notes.
Not only because of the delights available online,
But the researchers found that computer-literate people handle information superficially.
In contrast to the literal transmission of text,
Rewrite information in your own handwriting style
Linked to better test performance.
In order to maintain these observations:
"Study Studying"
A French experiment was conducted in two groups
They learned the Swahili translation of sixteen French words over two blocks
The first group studied in the morning and then got some rest
Then I studied again in the evening
But the second group studied in the evening and then slept at night and completed the study in the morning
Although the interval between the two blocks is equal
But the group that slept was able to remember 10 words out of 16 words
While the other group managed to remember only seven and a half words!
Do you want to learn new motor skills? If you try changing your exercises a bit!
A study of 86 healthy volunteers,
And asked them to teach computer-based skills during two training sessions.
I learned one of the two groups in the second important assignment in a slightly different way,
While the other group returned the task in exactly the same way.
Who used two different strategies that doubled the speed of the task
Compared to the other group.
How does it look in the real world?
To say that you have evolved from tennis, try to change the weights of your opponents a bit between the pieces
However, researchers are advised to avoid making very large changes
For example, switching between tennis and badminton
There is no progress in playing tennis!
Can not focus? Do some exercise!
A study showed that people who practice a stationary bike for 15 minutes
Then they accomplish a mental task, which they can accomplish faster than the group that did not exercise.
Even a quick tour of the park will make your mind clear.
Are you trying to save the electromagnetic spectrum in ascending order? Who do we do?
Try the "Recollection" method to shorten a sentence such as:
"Raging Martians Invaded Venus Using X-ray Guns" Angry Martians raided Venus using radiological guns.
This method has been proven in several experiments as a means of storing information in memory, has not it?
The theory suggests that adults can save a certain number of proverbs in short-term memory.
Collecting elements through "memorization" allows the brain to retain a lot of information.
Thus contributing to the creation of long-term memory.
Preferably the sentence is strange, the distinctive sentence entrenched in mind more boring.
Also read aloud.
I give people a list of singles, half of them reading silently and half loudly.
They were given a new list asking them to identify the words mentioned in the previous list.
They could remember the words they read louder than they read silently.
You do not need to think just make sure you are refreshed "Drink plenty of water"
In a study the participants held fast and refrained from liquids since the evening of the previous day.
And asked them to perform the reaction test.
A 500 ml set of water was given before the test unlike the other group.
The group that drank the water before the test performed much better
This is because water helps improve mental processing and learning.
After all that effort reward yourself.
A study has shown that equivalency stimulates education. In one study the bonus was cash.
Resulting in increased memory configuration which increased by increasing the value of the bonus.
This finding highlighted the effect of reward incentive on memory formation,
By releasing fewer dopamine in the brain before learning.
If you are really keen to learn quickly, check out Brilliant.org's sponsor for this episode
It is one of the best places to learn.
They like us, think if you are enthusiastic you will learn quickly.
And that interactive learning is the best and questions that ignite curiosity are very important.
When we want to develop our logical thinking or understand the experiences around us
Or trying to understand the physics of what happens around us daily
Brilliant site
It is a great way to challenge your mind easily and you can master the basic concepts through problem-solving tests.
Take a look at their site!
Tell us how you helped you learn faster
Sign up for clips every Thursday!
Translate team @autrjim